Hello.
Hello there.
Hi. I don't know if you remember me. Uh,
I spoke to you when David and Jai and
Doc were here.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
And you me?
Oh, wow. Yeah. How you doing?
I'm good. Uh, sorry. I know it's not the
topic. I just wanted to You said you're
invested now.
Yes, I am invested. So, what you got for
me? Uh so after our conversation I uh I
I took Jai no sorry doc is the woman.
Yes. Her advice and
I uh I just called to Jesus to reveal
himself.
Yeah. Uh and then I had I had some few
more dreams and uh something something
personal that I've been praying for for
years came true
which I didn't even ask him for that you
know I just wanted to reply.
Yeah.
That just shocked me.
Wow. Glory to God. Uh, of course my mom
she knew about this and she said that
it's it's just temporary and that uh
although it's it's a good thing for me
that uh Allah will uh will ruin it
somehow because it's a false it's like a
I don't know how to explain it like a he
wanted to test me. So he gave it to me
in the name, you know, put put in my
head that it's from Jesus,
but he's going to take it away from me
because it was just a test.
No way.
Wow. No way in the world. Wow. That's
amazing.
Yeah. I went to church also first time.
This is a Catholic church and I don't
know the difference, but I was confused.
Uh is it okay if I can take your time
now or?
Yeah. Yep. Yep. You sure can. I just
just to clarify for for the audience
listening um because you uh I don't I
don't know your position now but have
you you uh when we spoke you were a
Muslim at that time right
and then
yes but I was questioning
right
right and so now as where you stand are
you still within Islam but still
question or have you left Islam and
no I don't believe it's a religion I
mean it's I don't like to use the word
cult But
yeah,
that's what
But that's what it is.
When I compared it to Christianity,
especially after I went to church and
got to speak to the uh priest.
Mhm.
I was just shocked at the difference.
And that's, you know, that's what I
imagined Islam is.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Incredible.
So I left. Uh yeah.
Wow. That's amazing. Glory to God,
sister. this is uh you you're I first of
all I want to thank you for coming back
because like you said I I was invested
and I still am. So it's uh you um you
you coming back is is has blessed me.
It's blessed the stream is a good way to
start this off. So but yeah, you can ask
me you can ask me whatever you want.
Yeah. I was just confused because do
Christians believe that Jesus's mother
died or was she also raised to heaven
with him?
We Yeah. Yeah. So she she experienced
death. She she died and uh she's in
heaven now.
Okay. Because the uh there was a prayer
there obviously to Jesus, but then also
there was a prayer to Mary.
I see.
Confused like they're praying to her or
for her because she's she's a dead
person. But they were it sounded like
they were praying to her.
Yeah. So from a from the Catholic point
of view um because everybody who dies
who um in Christ like who has died as a
believer, they're in heaven with the
Lord now. And so um so they they they
use this verse like this. Let me uh show
you a verse and and how they understand
this. Um let me see. Let me go to let's
do this really quick here. The living
not okay. All right. Luke 20 verse 28.
Okay. So, let's pull this up really
quick. Luke 20. Luke 20 28. Okay. So,
this is what um this kind of comes from.
And let me see. Let me just put it on
the screen so you can see as well. All
right. So, it'll be it's over here on
the on the right the right hand side
over here. Okay. Let me zoom in too to
make sure we can see this. Okay. All
right. So it it starts off like this. So
the there came to him to came to Jesus
some Sadducees those who deny that there
is a resurrection and they asked him a
question saying teacher Moses wrote for
us that if a man's brother dies having a
wife but no children the man must take
the widow and rise up offspring for his
brother. Now there were seven brothers.
The first took a wife and died without
children. And the second and the third
took her. And likewise all seven left no
children and died. Afterward the woman
also died. In the resurrection therefore
whose wife will the woman be? For the
seven had her as a wife. And Jesus said
to them, the sons of this age marry and
are given in marriage. But those who are
considered worthy to attain to that age
and to the resurrection from the dead
neither marry nor are given in marriage.
for they cannot die anymore because they
are equal to angels and are sons of God
being sons of the resurrection but that
the the dead are raised. Even Moses
showed in this in the passage about
about the bush where he calls the Lord
the God of Abraham and the God of Isaac
and the God of Jacob. So notice how he's
calling them. He's not the god and he's
not it didn't say he used to be the god
of Abraham, Isaac, and Jac, but
presently he is the God of Abraham and
the God of Isaac and the God of Jacob
even though they died, right? And so
Jesus says now he is not the God of the
dead but of the living for all live to
him. Right?
So even though Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob, they passed from this life, since
they're with the Lord, they are alive to
God. And so um they are not dead but
they're even more alive than even we are
in this plane. So those who are
believers who die are even more alive
because they're with the Lord, right?
And so they the Catholics believe that
the same thing about Mary. They believe
that she's, you know, obviously she died
a believer and is with the Lord now,
right? And so therefore
son or
Yes. Yes. Yes. with her son with God the
father with the son Jesus, right? And so
um um they they believe that they can
you know basically ask her to intercede
for them on their behalf. They believe
that Mary since she's with the Lord with
her with Jesus in heaven that she can um
basically pray for them um on their
behalf to to the Lord. So that's that's
where they believe. So they they believe
she's alive in heaven like in this in
this sense, not that she didn't die here
on earth, but that she's alive as a
believer in heaven because she's with
the Lord in heaven.
Okay. Uh I I wanted to ask you because
when now I can say when I was a Muslim,
it feels weird to say. I was taught that
you I should fear Allah.
Yeah. So the concept of hell didn't
really I didn't think about it. It was
obvious that if I should fear him
obviously he's going to punish me. But
with Jesus all I hear is that he's love.
Yeah.
So here it doesn't make sense to me why
there is hell because with Allah it
makes sense because he's you should fear
him. But with Jesus, you should, you
know, love him and he loves you. And so,
yeah. So, so the the idea of hell in
Christianity is not to to be based out
of fear, but it's God's justice, you
know. Um, as believers, those who come
to the Lord, we have nothing to fear of
that. Like, we're believers. We're not
going to face hell at all. And, um,
um, when it comes to hell, Jesus says
that hell was created for the devil. and
the angels that followed the devil,
right? The ones who he convinced to go
against God in heaven to rebel. And so,
it wasn't really originally made for
human beings, but for the wicked angels
and and the devil himself. However,
because God is just, um, he will not
allow the even the wicked to enter into
his kingdom. Um, even after they die or
on the day of judgment, they're going to
be judged. And so because God is just,
he has to judge the wicked and he can't
let sin go. He has to punish it, which
hell is the punishment. So, um, that's
that's why that's the concept of hell
within the Bible. It's not to scare
people or because, oh, God is just so
wrathful. No, God is just he's loving
and he's just at the same time. So, we
can't forget like we know that God is
love. And because he's loving, he's also
just at the same time. So he's not going
to let sin just get swept under the rug.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it makes sense.
Okay.
So that's that's that.
Thank you.
But yes, you're still exploring, right?
Still exploring, still learning.
Yeah. I uh Yes. After our conversation
before I called to Jesus. I read I just
wanted to read the Bible to see what you
were talking about
and I read uh I think I read all of Luke
already.
Yeah. Wow.
It was it was like a month ago and we
spoke and but I read it in one night.
Oh, praise God. Yeah.
Yeah. And uh I I because I I was
wondering do can you follow only the
gospels which is what Jesus like the the
things Jesus said or do you have to
believe believe and follow the whole
Bible old and new testament?
Yeah. So all all of it is tethered
together Miam. So um like if you if you
believe like notice I'll show you
another verse. This is what Jesus says
here. Um and this is why we as
Christians believe not just in the
gospel writings right but of all the
scripture um even the Old Testament
because of this. So I'm going to show
you this verse here and u
and the Old Testament is the Jewish
Torah, correct? Or
Yeah, that's the uh that's the Torah,
right? That's the Torah and that's all
the prophets that you know came before
Jesus was born in human form. Okay. So
Jesus says this in John five and he said
and this is really really important. If
we go to John 5 and we go down to around
let's say the uh let's say here
okay yes here it is um verse uh let's
let's do verse 39. So this is John 5:39
right here. Okay. It says, "You search
the scriptures because you think that in
them you have eternal life. And it is
that they but and it is they that bear
witness about me." So Jesus says the
scriptures which the Jews are using bear
witness about him. Okay? And he says yet
you refuse to come to me that you may
have life. I do not receive glory from
people, but I know that you do not have
the love of God within you. I have come
in my father's name, and you do not
receive me. If another comes in his own
name, you will receive him. How can you
believe when you receive glory from one
another and do not seek the glory that
comes only from God? Do not think that I
will accu Do you do not think that I
will accuse you to the father? There is
one who accuses you, Moses, on whom you
have set your hope. For if you believed
Moses, you would believe me, for he
wrote of me. But if you do not believe
his writings, how will you believe my
words? So Jesus points to the writings
of Moses as a testimony, as a witness to
him as the Messiah, who's the one who
gives life. So they're they're trying to
trust like the the scriptures thinking
that the scriptures will give them life.
But Jesus is saying, "No, the scriptures
just point you to me. I'm the one who
gives you life and these scriptures
point you to me, but you reject the
scriptures. You reject me because you
really don't believe the scriptures."
Okay?
So, so it is very important that we take
the Old Testament and we read through it
and we accept it because this is all of
it is a setup. the the Old Testament is
God setting up the coming of the
Messiah. That's really what what it is.
Obviously, it's tethered with other
stories and histories, but the main
theme of it is all foreshadowing the
coming of the Messiah.
Okay. How is Because my friend uh she's
a Christian and she told me to read the
Bible, but she said, "Don't read the Old
Testament."
She said, "Just read read the Gospels.
Don't read the Old Testament."
Yeah. God God bless her heart. But yes,
read read the New Testament and read the
Old Testament as well. I I would say
read the New Testament first because
that's you get Jesus, you know, you get
Jesus, you get the gospel, you get what
he did, what he taught, and then go to
the Old Testament because I'm going tell
you with the Old Testament, it makes
what Jesus did and said even more
beautiful because you'll see where it's
coming from. You'll see how he's tying
in the prophets and and you'll see how
consistent throughout the generations of
the prophets hundreds of years apart
from each other and you know generations
apart from each other still saying the
same thing and pointing to the coming of
the Messiah. That's how beautiful it is.
So that's it's very important that we
have the Old Testament because it
testifies to Jesus. It makes him even
more beautiful than what he already is.
Okay. Okay.
So, yeah, definitely read the Old
Testament, too.
Okay.
All right. Well, yeah, if you if you
have any other questions for me,
remember I told you you can I don't care
what the topic is, you can come up and
uh and come talk to me. Okay.
Not a question, but you know, I was very
surprised at the church. Uh first of
all, that there's no segregation like
women and men.
Yeah.
And the priest in the end, he was
standing and he was shaking hands with
women.
Culture shock, huh?
Yeah. Yes, it was. I mean, I live across
from the church, but I never went
inside. So,
in my head, it was a mosque.
And I felt so guilty like my ex-Muslim
brain
felt so guilty looking at the cross and
looking at pictures of Jesus on the
press.
Well, yeah, you you you have left that
behind, sister. You are you are in
Christ and you can worship in freedom.
And and that's what it is in
Christianity.
It made me so sad. Like it it looked
horrible like Jesus on the cross. It
made me sad and feel bad for him.
Yeah, that's the that's the point. The
point is is is how we can it's what they
do is they give us a somewhat of a
visual of what it might have looked
like. And even that's not doing it
justice cuz it's worse than what what
it's being what's what's being shown to
you. And so but that's what he that's
what he did for us. He went through all
of that, that type of humiliation, that
type of suffering and pain because he
loved us so that we wouldn't have to be
strung up.
I didn't know that he had to carry his
own cross.
Yeah. I thought after being whipped and
beat.
Yeah. I thought it was just because uh
in the church here they have pictures of
the I don't know in English how it's
called. It directly translates to the
road the uh road of the cross.
The mass of the road of the cross. Yes.
Mhm.
That's that's the literal translation
from my language. And it had pictures of
like important stages and I was in shock
that I thought they just crucified him
and that's it.
But
they beat him. They made him carry his
own cross that it was Yeah. It was
horrible.
It was gruesome. It was It was terrible.
Yep. And so that's uh that's what our
Lord has done for us and that's why we
as Christians we respond in a way that
gives honor to him and and it's love
like thank you.
Just thank you cuz there's nothing we
can do to substitute that. We couldn't
do that. We could we couldn't do that
but he came and did it for us. So
I would have crucified myself like like
that's really unimaginable pain.
Exactly.
Yeah. It was beautiful but very sad and
very empathetic. So it was horrible.
Yep. That's the gospel. That's the
gospel. But thank you so much, Miam. I
love you so much, sister. God bless you.
Stay strong. We're praying for you.
Okay.
Yes, please. Thank you.
All right. God bless you. Take care. All
right, guys. That is our new sister,
Miam, who has recently left Islam. Uh
last time we spoke, she was uh still a
Muslim, just, you know, very
questionable. Uh, and then she called
out to Christ and he answered. He
answered and, uh, appeared to her. Um,
gave her what she's asked, what she
asked for. And that's that's just
beautiful. Hold on a second. Fix that.
Yeah. So, glory to God, man. Glory to
God for another new sister in in in
Christ. She came to our panels, was
watching the videos, came on the
streams. Um, I don't I don't even know,
man. It's God is just amazing what he's
been doing with the ministry. And shout
out to Giant DLC also cuz I remember I
remember that stream like I told her
like I will bring Giant DLC just for
you. And uh she showed up on that
stream. They came and uh she showed up.
So, glory to God.